speaking of Michael man um if someone
has never seen any of his films besides
Ferrari which obviously is the easy
answer what's the one you want to
recommend people watch first and why oh
gosh that's a great question I mean my
favorite debatably is heat I just
there's H the everything about that film
and every single time I watch it I think
that's actually my favorite part about
heat is every time I watch it I feel
attracted to something new in it like
the first time it was more sort of the
the violence that was occurring between
the men and their relationships and then
the second time it was the emotional
violence that was occurring between all
of their the love um and the romance and
I just I think it's a it's just a
perfect film in my eyes I love it and so
obviously you're working with Michael
and Ferrari a lot of rumors that uh you
know he's making a sequel to heat are
you sort of like you know I love this
movie is there a role I mean of course
absolutely the thing I remember when we
were filming Ferrari Michael gave me he
heat too came out and he gave me a
signed copy of it and um and anel Elgort
happened to be in town while we were
filming and came by to visit Michael
because he had worked with him on Tokyo
Vice and so we were reading heat too
together and and just talking about it
and it's such a it's such a fun Daydream
you know to work with someone that you
love so much that you could only hope to
be able to work with them again one day
and and whether it's working together or
just championing championing him on um
for the rest of his career I just feel
very like blessed and very grateful to
have had the opportunity to work with
him at all I also really enjoy Tokyo
Vice and I another just thing I'm
recommending it's very good I am so
curious you've done some really cool
stuff in your career and obviously
Ferrari what's the most nervous you've
been the night before the first day of
filming and why every single project
I've ever done it never the nerves never
go away and I think there's something so
important about that if I wasn't nervous
if I felt I do have a I have a
confidence in what I do because I I feel
proud of it and I feel dedicated to it
so there's a confidence that comes with
that but that confidence is is only
mirrored by nerves as well um I think
that chaotic energy is what drives
passion in a way last question I think
I'm almost out of time with Ferrari what
uh as a fan of Michael man what actually
surprised you about the collaboration
with him on set and what was it about
this project that said I absolutely have
to do this you know I I don't think this
is any secret going into a Michael Man
film a lot of people are like oh you're
working with Michael man GNA be tough or
it's going to be this or it's going to
be that there's there are so many
preconceived ideas that i' had been
given and I'm not one to really take
much for truth until I experience it
myself and I of course it was tough only
because the stakes were high and I
wanted to I wanted to do Justice by his
intuition do justice towards like his
vision for this film and and my
character but I thrive around people who
are so passionate and who are so
dedicated to their craft and Michael is
is a master of that um so for me I
didn't find it to be overwhelming or too
tough or um or frustrating because of
his attention to detail i i thrived in
the environment and it became addicting
it was an energy that I really enjoyed
being around because it only ever is in
support of the greater picture it's only
ever in support of the final product and
um I think that there's an incredible
amount of leadership that has to come
with being a director and and it is a it
is a dying art and I think there is a a
lost breed of people who have the
stamina and the attention to detail that
Michael has and so every single moment
of the experience felt like an
opportunity to soak it up to not forget
I would take take notes um I would talk
to his crew cuz a lot of his crew
members had worked with him for decades
and there's also something to be said
about that you know someone who who has
people who desire to work with him again
and again and again and it's because no
matter the circumstance and maybe the
temporary chaos that might be um might
be happening Michael pushes everyone to
be the best that they can possibly be
because he pushes himself to be the best
he can possi be and that is again it's
just a very addicting um wonderful
energy to be around when you're in the
process of creating art on that note
congratulations on this and I do hope
you get a roll in heat too oh me too I'm
like I'll be the bartender I don't care
I'll do
anything